The answer is here we're doing a nested loop,
and the way we do a nested loop is the way we did the first loop--
by calling extend prefix. What is the word so far that we've built up?
It's the w we had before, and now we're looping through the letters,
so we want to add the letter L to the end of that.
Now what are the remaining letters we have in order to add into that word?
That's the letters we had before with L removed.
That's all there is to it.
Now if we test words again, the speed is almost the same--0.003 something,
but the function is more concise, more readable, and more general
in that it will take any number of letters.
Now, there are a lot of variations on this.
If you type "import this" into a Python interpreter you get out a little set of aphorisms,
almost like a poem, called "The Zen of Python" by Tim Peters.
One of them says "Flat is better than nest."
We can take out this nested function.
Instead of having it in here, we can make it flat like that.
I've also made a small change here in that removed works
when you're removing any number of letters.
Here if I only want to remove one letter, I can just call the built-in method letters.replace directly.
When we call test_words() on this just to make sure we haven't broken anything,
it verifies okay, and the speed is about the same.
You can keep it like this. This is a good approach. I'm pretty happy with this one.
But notice what we're doing here--find_words() is sort of a wrapper to extend_prefix(),
which takes letters and adds in two more extra arguments--
the prefix that we found so far and the results that we want to accumulate the results into.
Instead of having one function call a second, we could do this all in one function
if we made these two extra things be optional arguments.
We could do it like that--where we just have one function find_words(),
which takes letters, and then the optional prefix of our end results to accumulate into.
Now in terms of pacing, let's stop here.
Let's congratulate ourselves and say we've done our job.
We've come up with find_words(), and we said for any set of letters
I can find all the words in the dictionary that correspond to that hand of letters.
Furthermore, I can do that at a speed of 2000 hands per second,
which seems pretty good. We've achieved our first milestone.
Now we should think--first I guess we should relax, congratulate ourselves,
have a drink or whatever it is you need to do,
and then when you're ready to come back then we can start the next leg of the journey.